all right so the Lakers with a late 10-1
run comes down to this play right here
LeBron James kicking it out cam redish
for three gets a great
look doesn't fall though great look
though it's a great look now I'm going
to say it was the wrong pass Kristen
wood should have been the pass that's
the drop off the drop off now this the
point guard in me talking right the
point guard is like a drawu Christian
Woodman came to me we down one I'm I'm
I'm dropping that to Woods right under
see he got his man sealed so I'm
dropping that to Wood I ain't going for
the three but in today's age we are
taught like take the jump shot shoot the
three you know go for the wind and the
move was here Christian Woodman came I
drop it right to Woods Woods under the
basket he lays it up LeBron took the
long long pass to the corner they shot
the the three and Miss but that's the
point guard of me talking I know LeBron
made the right basketball play but there
are going to be people obviously
frustrated that LeBron didn't take this
in himself that' have been a terrible
shot if he' to took it he probably would
have got it
blocked maybe fouled though
maybe but I mean that's Jimmy Butler
good Defender then you got bam coming
over right timed it he you know he ain't
jumping 40 Ines no more he put that pass
on the string watching it like it was
seamed up lined up great shot especially
with reddish but I think what happened
was looking at the play again when
Butler stuck his hand in right there
that man messed up his rhythm of and
changed his plan of what he was going to
do so the Lakers dropping to three and
four and this one's going to be tough
for them to swallow because Anthony
Davis leaving again with that hip spasm
had nine points in 25 minutes LeBron
plays 37 minutes has a 30 they get a
better performance Austin Reeves who had
23 they were right there made that late
run and then comes down to that and you
lose the game you lose the game but you
love that they fought back even though
you lost Davis and you hope it's not
serious you're glad to see Austin Reed
find his rhythm because they're going to
need him going forward he he's he was a
big piece of what they did last year he
had timely shots and to see him get his
swag back he hit his shot and start
doing this again I'm like okay he's
feeling good about himself and even
though he lost Davis for a little bit
that could be a win for them going
forward yeah coming off a game uh Austin
Reed had 20 points against Orlando so
again building on that but we we got to
talk about bam at a bio here these
numbers 22 points 20 rebounds 10
assists I mean 22 20 and 10 them is
Miami prom League numbers like he was
that's Miami PR League numb Z but but
you can see the culture shift now being
built around bam in sposta and Bam
that's what you're going to see that
that is the morning that's Lonzo morning
and Riley you you know you I I can see
that forming you know bam sposta this
the culture this is what we're going to
build and this is how he's going to play
in this offense because this offense
really is designed so bam can get off
it's more of a a read and react passing
game type of offense not a lot of play
calls so bam is featured in the middle
they play through him and he's able to
do his thing Jimmy Butler adding 282
again we talked about him off the top in
the pregame hasn't been healthy but
performances like this definitely going
to help the Miami Heat who go on to win
their third game of the season